hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university calm
thank you and enjoy
okay so first up in cholesterol
synthesis stage one is basically making
mevalonate so we said that methyl on a
we make it by combining three acetyl co
a we're going to start here with two
acetyl co a z' and I've numbered them
here as one two three four four their
carbons two two carbon units we're going
to bring them together and actually
connect the second carbon with two the
third carbon when I connect make a
connection here between these two
carbons and kick off this coenzyme a
gonna kick that coenzyme a off co ash
and we're going to get this acetyl
acetyl co a and which is just a four
carbon acyl Co a and this is done by
file ace which you might have or you
might be able to recall thiolase was in
beta oxidation it basically catalyzed
the reverse of this right we'd have an
acyl co a it would cut off a seat Alcoa
way by adding a coenzyme a so thiolase
can catalyze the forward and reverse
reaction here and it happens to be the
first step in my belong a synthesis once
we have this acetyl acetyl co a we're
going to add the the other acetyl co a
so this this next acetyl co a again
right here with two carbons that's going
to be added and we're going to connect
that we're going to connect carbon
number six to carbon number three so
it's kind of a weird little connection
here where I connect carbon number six
to carbon number three here and what's
going to happen is that this this
carbonyl group oxygen is not going to
become an O H and this this carbon
number four gets kicked up here to
become a methyl group on this chain and
of course this coenzyme a leaves what we
get is this molecule called beta hydroxy
beta methyl group TR o co a which is a
six carbon molecule and it's otherwise
known as HM G Co a the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is called
hmg-coa synthase which you might have
come across some other time
I haven't actually talked about it but
there there is another isozyme of
hmg-coa synthase and I have a question
over here listed where is the other eyes
design and what pathway or processes
said I so Simon's all involved in or
with before I answer that question I
want to say that these first few steps
that are bound here by this sort of a
light pink bracket these first two steps
occur in the cytosol of the cell so this
hmg-coa synthase is the cytosolic eyes
design
and the the other eyes design is located
in the mitochondria and the pathway or
process that it's involved in is ketone
body synthesis which is something that
we actually haven't talked about in any
of my videos quite yet at least as of
the recording of this video but it's
something that I may discuss another
time one thing that I do want to mention
about hmg-coa is kind of breaking down
its name to see if it makes a little bit
of sense because this is kind of a crazy
molecule and I remember when I first saw
it it looked kind of weird to me and I
didn't really totally understand the
name but um I understand it now and I
kind of want to see if you guys can help
if I can get you guys to think about
this name in the structure fairly well
so um the beta hydroxy beta methyl part
that should make a little bit of sense
when we think about the fact that we
have a carbonyl and we have a carbon
immediately adjacent to it that carbon
immediately adjacent to it is an alpha
that's really small
make that a little bit bigger it's the
alpha carbon so that's an alpha carbon
there an alpha carbon there immediately
adjacent to carbonyl groups the next
carbon over would be the beta carbon so
here we have this carbon being the beta
carbon so on this beta carbon there's a
hydroxy group and a methyl group so beta
hydroxy beta methyl should make sense
now what about this glued Tirol portion
glue Tirico a the coalition makes sense
because there's a coins I may attach
there but the gluteal will glue taro I
think about glutamates so let's kind of
compare this structure to the glutamate
that I've drawn here so if we think
about the right side of this molecule
we've got this
carboxyl group just like we have over
here right we have this carboxyl group
okay and in glutamate at the alpha
carbon we have an amino group here at
this alpha card and we don't have
anything but in the R group of glutamate
the amino acid we have ch2 ch2 and then
another carboxyl group here we don't
have a ch2 but we do have a carbon and
then another carbon and then what would
have been a car or carboxyl group if
this coenzyme a wasn't here okay
so this this basically is a gluteal Co a
if we ignore the beta hydroxy in beta
methyl portion well really the only
difference between these guys is that
there's a coenzyme a here right and at
the beta portion there's two
substituents hydroxyl group in the
methyl group so hopefully that name
makes a little bit more sense and if you
have to memorize the structure for any
course that you're taking that break
down hopefully helps a little bit so all
of these reactions so far to make
hmg-coa occurred in the cytosol next up
we're going to go to the endoplasmic
reticulum where if you recall it's the
organelle that lipid synthesis really
occurs and we're talking about
cholesterol synthesis cholesterol is a
lipid so we're going to take hmg-coa and
we're going to turn it into Melville on
a so that's a last step in this process
and what basically happens is that the
part of the molecule that changes as its
left side labeled and brown the the the
carbonyl group becomes an alcohol so
there was a reduction done there and we
also got rid of this coenzyme a so the
coenzyme a portion fell off and there
was also a reduction happening here and
so a reducing agent must have been
required and in this case we're talking
about biosynthesis so it should make
sense that we're adding NADPH as
actually to NADPH is required here and
we're going to get off to nadp+ --is
NADPH I think is what I said I hope I
didn't mess that up NADPH is our use
here and we get we get mauville on 8v
enzyme that catalyzes this reaction is
hmg-coa reductase
and there are a bunch of stars around
this and the reason why is because this
particular step is the committed step
this is the committed step in
cholesterol biosynthesis in addition to
being the committed step meaning that
this mevalonate is now committed to
cholesterol synthesis ice totally
spelled that wrong they're supposed to
be synthesis okay this molecule of Alana
is committed to cholesterol synthesis
but also this this step is the rate
limiting step of the entire process so
not only is bevel on a committed to it
but this reaction happens the slowest
and thus it's the the rate limiting step
so it's going to be highly regulated so
this is the control point for
cholesterol synthesis so it's definitely
something you should keep in mind okay
so now that we've made an Avalon eight
we're done with stage one so we're on to
stage two so I'll see you hopefully in
the next video thank you for watching
thanks for watching and be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone new thing might find it
helpful thanks happy studying